What's the scariest painting and Art
History?
There are some strong contenders,
like the judgment of Kumbaya by Gerard
divvied Hieronymus.
Bosch is rendering the Henry Fuselli
nightmare edvard moocs screen,
but there's only ever really been one
painting that has seriously disturbed
me.
This one,
Francisco Goya's,
Saturn devouring his son.
What you're seeing here is the legendary
Spanish painters depiction of the Greek
Titan cronus,
who after usurping power from his father
was told a prophecy that one of his own
sons would do the same,
and you serve him in order to prevent
this.
Every time his Queen Raya bore a child,
kronis would eat it.
Unfortunately for him in the end,
ray conspired to hide away their
youngest son,
Zeus,
who eventually fulfilled the prophecy,
exiled his father and ended the reign of
the titans.
The story is a well known Greek myth,
but look at how Goya handles it.
Some key changes jump out right away.
First,
in the myth,
cronus devours his children by
swallowing them whole.
In fact,
they remain alive in his stomach.
Goya's painting is a much more gruesome
affair.
He takes some inspiration here from
Peter Paul Rubens,
a flemish baroque painter who depicted
the same event as well in Rubin,
Saturn.
The tightened seems to be sucking the
life force from his child even for such
a terrifying subject matter.
Ruben's displays all the drama richness,
even beauty that marks the baroque
style.
He helped to make famous
in Goias version.
That beauty is gone.
We're left with a frightened,
crazed monster discovered in the dark as
if by some explorer with a torch who
wandered into the wrong cave.
Saturn kronis his Roman name as already
chewed off the head of his child is
black mouth,
opens around the elbow of the left arm,
ready to bite it off.
At the joint is angular.
Body is crouching in an awkward
position.
His hands dig into the spine.
Blood runs down his child's arm and neck
and shoulder,
a startling primary color,
and if we take a closer look,
we notice that this is not a child at
all,
but one of Saturn's kids grown up.
There's something even more terrifying
in knowing that the victim knew what was
happening and tried to fight back,
but what's most disturbing of all,
I think is when and where this painting
was found late in his life.
Francisco Goya purchased a house on the
outskirts of Madrid called the Quinta
Dale Sordo,
or the villa of the deaf after its
previous owner,
and interesting coincidence since by
that time in his life,
Goya was deaf to his physical and mental
health,
declining.
Goya painted.
14 murals often refer to as the black
paintings directly onto the interior
walls of his home.
Saturn devouring his son was in the
dining room.
The photographs you're seeing now,
we're taking over 50 years.
After that time,
Goya never mentioned the paintings
himself.
He never intended for anyone to see
them.
To this day,
people still puzzle over the meaning of
the black paintings.
Why was Goya creating these pessimistic
and fantastical scenes in the solitude
of his home to understand this,
it might help to go back through his
career.
He grew up in Zara,
Goza,
Spain,
the fourth of six children in a lower
middle class family.
By all accounts,
he was a lighthearted and joyful kid as
he studied painting in Zara,
goes up,
Madrid and Rome.
His first serious job was at the royal
tapestry factory where he created
tapestry cartoons to adorn the palaces
and stately homes of the city.
These tapestries take their cue from the
Rococo style,
elegant,
playful,
light scenes of both nobility and
peasantry,
enjoying the normal activities of their
day.
Goya eventually became the court painter
for King Charles the fourth,
a disappointing monarch,
unlike his father Charles,
the third who was beloved by the people
for enacting reforms that began to bring
secular enlightenment values to Spain in
1793 and unknown
left Goya,
yet though he still took emissions from
his royal clientele.
This disease was a dark time
turning point in his life and art.
You can see it in yard with lunatics
from 1794.
Bodies Grapple and cry out in anguish.
The difference between this and the
tapestry cartoons is shocking.
His hearing gone.
Goya began to see the country around him
with a grim clarity and a series of
etchings called Los Capriccio or the
caprices.
He sends up a Spanish culture that is
both tragic and comic,
a student of the enlightenment himself.
Goya sees the country backsliding on the
road to maternity.
The king is withdrawn and the people are
superstitious,
too stupid to know what they need.
You can see him fusing all the corners
of his imagination,
the quest for anatomical truth,
the need for social critique and an
obsession with beasts and creatures.
It's all summed up in this one.
Aptly titled,
the sleep of reason produces monsters.
In the following years,
things got worse for Spain.
Napoleon invaded the country and
brutally massacred those who resisted
his campaign.
Goya was witnessed to the bloodshed and
it affected him deeply.
His painting on the subject,
the third of May 18,
oh,
eight is a regulatory depiction of war,
resistance and brutality.
Before this war was a highly composed
theatrical subject.
In painting here,
Goya gives nothing but brute force.
It's emotion unmediated by artifice.
It would be five years until Spain
regained its thrown.
In the interim,
resistors developed the constitution of
18,
12,
which called for liberal reforms like
national sovereignty,
freedom of the press and free
enterprise,
but on gaining power.
The new King Ferdinand,
the seventh squash the constitution
right away and arrested those who made
it Goya,
withdrew disheartened the country which
in his youth had reached toward a new
world,
was now swallowed again by autocracy,
scarred by war,
scarred by illness.
He began to paint nightmare scenes onto
the walls of his home.
In one,
a young man is being eaten by the
father.
He was prophesied to you.
Serve by now.
Goya knows progress isn't assured,
and when it's defeated,
it's not painless,
it's horrific and slow and the victim
can feel it happening.
There are a lot of ways that you can
read Saturn devouring his son.
Maybe Goya was trying to exercise the
demons of his mind or the demons of his
country,
or maybe he was just trying to paint
honestly about one terrifying facet of
man's nature using the skills and
techniques he learned in pioneered
through a lifetime.
The black paintings changed the history
of art,
but what's maybe scariest of all is that
Goya didn't care.
He doesn't care how we read this
painting because he didn't paint it for
us or for anyone.
Saturn devouring his son exists beyond
interpretation.
It's brute force horror without
mediation,
a monster looking out from a dark wall
in a dark room.
Hey everybody,
thank you so much for watching.
This episode was brought to you by
squarespace.
If you want to make a website and you
want it to be a really,
really easy process,
squarespace has some beautiful award
winning designer templates to choose
from that makes making a website so
simple.
It's got 24 hour customer service,
no upgrades,
nothing to install,
no patches ever,
and picking your domain name is really
easy.
You can start your free
trial@squarespace.com,
and if you use the offer code
nerdwriter,
you can get 10 percent off your first
purchase.
Thanks guys.
I'll see you next time.